you got it that's not all [ __ ] bro
oh my god it's so disturbing i
knew it so
you got it who made it am i dead
not yet that's what should be great
is it but you will be unless you come
with us
let's give you a vengeance
ridiculous he looks so ridiculous
it's classic loki oh my god oh my god
welcome back to new rock stars loki
episode 4 confirmed our
theories about the timekeepers just
being puppets controlled by someone else
it pruned off mobius and loki just to
reveal life after prunin
and suggested the most dangerous nexus
events are apparently formed by loving
yourself too hard and if
that is the case i created two and a
half nexus eventually in this episode
but
wait a damn minute
this is inside marvel it's new
rockstar's loki after show i'm eric voss
my easter egg breakdown of the episode
is coming tomorrow but here with me to
discuss this episode is
mt hey empty dude what a doozy of an
episode like i know holy crap i mean
like i heard that they were saying that
episode four was gonna
be crazy but like i didn't know it was
gonna be like this and oh my god it's so
good to see sif
it's so good it was so good to see seth
and jamie alexander was just here for it
she's like you're giving me what six
lines that i'm just gonna say on loop
whatever
i'm gonna i can do that easy easy
paycheck
it means so much to love about this
episode and oh by the way mt
just a huge thank you to you and jess
clemens last week for
having me covered it was nice to just
get some r and r that i desperately
needed
and uh you guys did a great job i love
your episode it was so good like doing
an
inside marvel with jess and like of
course we missed she's amazing it's
weird
having inside marvel without you so like
it's good to have you back but i love
you it was weird not to be with you on
wednesday i'll say that
um but um let's dive into this episode
this
insane episode yes so uh we learned that
sylvie was captured by the tva as a
young girl for no
apparent reason other than she was born
the goddess of mischief and then
fangirled over valkyrie i actually think
that might have been the reason she was
just going to be a hero they didn't
someone targeted loki's and she was
trying to you know
kill off his enemies or or get his
enemies captured we'll talk about that
in a bit
um but then back in lamentus we see some
sparks forming between her and loki and
their dying moments
and then that endless love erected a
raging branch
that alerts the tva to where they are
uh so they get arrested loki gets thrown
in a time cell on bloop with lady siff
beating them up again and again and
again definitely making up her absence
in ragnarok
and then ren slayer has poor c20
pruned um mainly because she has been
awakened to the truth
she knew too much she had to go so cold
uh but mobius and b15 see the light of
this
um which ends with poor mobius getting
pruned
oh so sad it was such a powerful seed
so sad but he's probably coming back
right um
and uh the time keepers are revealed
these goofy you know bill and ted time
lords floating in these chairs
uh but when b15 helps loki and silvi it
leads to still be decapitating one of
these timekeepers
revealing that they are mindless
androids and then right in this moment
rinslayer prunes loki
in the back and silly demands rinse
layer to tell her everything and loki
wakes up in the ruins of new york
finding richard e grant as
as as listed in the credits classic loki
along with
another dude who's listed as boastful
loki kid loki and
uh loca gator gator
al loki gator gator
i mean all you know this is in florida
what happens when a kid in a loki
costumes wanders too close to a
retention pond by disney world
that's the oregon story right there i
see this every day
um so the question posed at the end of
this episode is what we're going to be
talking about who really created the tva
but we're also going to be talking about
that crazy post credit scene all your
questions that you had after this
episode i'm sure there were many
but uh first if you'd like to support
the work we do here at new rockstars
and also make someone in your life
really happy head on over to new
rockstarsmerch.com and buy a gift for
that nerd in your life
uh gift that they'll love we have an
entire loki collection
augmented reality loki shirts miss
minute stickers and clocks but i'm
wearing our awesome latest obsession
shirt loki out of time mt has another tv
show
yeah i love that um but when you get
this uh loki out of time shirt it comes
in a couple different color varieties
when you get it you'll unlock the
ability to write in
an additional custom shout out that will
appear at the bottom of the screen in
these episodes so just to read a few who
do we got here we get to marco who says
calling it now
loki is amelia earhart
hey maybe we got two episodes left hey
maybe amelia earhart was a loki variant
the entire time who knows
who knows oh jeff says mobius and mobius
equals he who remains
hey that's an interesting idea um
interesting theory i don't know after
this episode if that after this episode
ex agreed mt yeah i think they'd have to
be
they got some more explaining to do if
that's the case but it's a possibility
uh and then passover says wolf you are
the only one i want to reset time with
love bear oh i don't know what that
means but that's super sweet
i hope it's not love comma bear i hope
it's just from love bear
i love bear that's just a cute name i
hope it's love bear too
hey this is why you gotta get some merch
on nerexosmirch.com to
show that love bear out seriously i love
them it's the perfect way to propose
i'm just kidding don't do that no i
think it is hey
do it if you want come on i take i
change it i change my mind
propose be a new rock star shirt it's
the best way to do it
so empty what let's talk what's our
first way to do a minute here
that's a good question our first way to
do a minute of the day is when are they
a minute if the timekeepers are androids
who really created the tva
yeah yeah okay so as we've been
suspecting uh
since i think the first episode of the
show even before the first episode while
the timekeepers themselves do
exist in some physical form they
themselves are not
real deities but they're just kind of
phony machinery created by someone else
we're really indeed looking at a wizard
of oz men behind the curtain scenario
which is exciting to see even though
it's a theory that we had it's like
the way it's presented with the thing
getting decapitated
sparks fall out i kind of love that it
was still satisfying even though like
yes you called it i was like oh [ __ ] as
soon as they started talking i'm like
that's some chucky cheese [ __ ] eric was
right so
what does this mean well right off the
bat i think we can assume everything
miss minutes told us about the sacred
timeline about next events and variants
the past multiversal war it was all most
likely [ __ ] right
um whatever that tva propaganda
department was the narrative commission
yeah it was all kind of
concocted now there may still be a
sacred timeline from which branches form
like as the ancient one explained in
endgame she did say like one timeline
there
i don't know if it is considered the
sacred timeline
uh and it was not created by these time
keepers uh there may
not have been a past multiversal war
that was brought to peace by them
and i think uh sylvia and other variants
probably were not targeted because they
create nexus offense
but in sylvie's case because she was
like maybe a hero who identified with
valkyrie like
all loki's may have been targeted
because they presented obstacles
and were enemies to whoever truly
created the tva
and that's what it's just kind of a
random kill list of people who get in
that person's way of what their
objectives are yeah it kind of reminds
me of wanted
you know like i don't know if remember
they wanted the weavers
the weird weavers they're like it's just
in the weave it's in the tapestry we
can't do anything about this
it's morgan freeman the entire time he's
um now when we're talking about who
created the tva in the comics the
timekeepers were constructed by someone
named he who remains we've talked about
this before
but just to remind you uh that is the
old old final tva agent at the end of
all time who's in his weird little
laboratory and he creates these things
to help the next universal cycle learn
the lessons from the past
also to store weird coronal energy that
they use for their retirement funds
it's crazy but i love it uh now
in the comics i don't believe they're
like you know sparks machines
gears you know they're kind of just like
organic created things
that do kind of have power you know they
do kind of rise to this
almost deity status but they were
created by someone who was like
lower than that it seems yes this series
may reveal
a character named t who remains we have
two episodes left um previously we had
theories that richard e grant might have
been playing that character but now we
see richard grant is playing this guy
named classic loki so i guess that's not
the case we'll talk about whoever that
is later but
uh despite the tva being built on lies
uh with the workforce of memory wiped
variants
it's still a very powerful institution
that can transcend time
detain powerful beings whose magic is
neutralized inside those boundaries
so someone gave the institution that
power to begin with
um so when we're talking about who would
have the ability and the interest to
manufacture this time variance authority
this bureaucracy
uh to preserve the flow of time in this
specific way
um who would fear loki variant so
much in order to do that this way
let's let's look at a couple different
options option a may
we may very well meet he who remains um
i don't know if they'll call this person
that
but in this case of the show he who
remains could be someone we've already
met maybe like ramona rinslayer or a
different mobius or even casey
poor okay the true master very wide
remains just like his mind wiped but he
created them in a past life
um maybe because we know that tva was
fully operational when ransallier was
still a hunter so i don't know if she
would be he who remains but she is kind
of the handler the
caretaker of the timekeepers knows their
true nature
you know um but i think the idea of this
option would be maybe there's just some
spineless tva agent from a past
universal cycle who's obsessed with
maintaining order and
they created it this way and and all the
clock work was created by them it's not
a huge deal who they are that would be
that option
yeah i do like that last option there
because like it because like i feel like
the tva
seems like an institution that has been
there because like you said they have
authority
someone gave them that authority like
you're not going to wake up be like i'm
just gonna
rule over time and space because i just
have that no like either like
i don't know if it's like living right
someone gave them that authority so like
he who remains
we're about to say the living tribunal
yes
maybe the living tribunal because like
he is sort of in charge of the
multiverse he's the multiverse
man so he has the final say so like
maybe judge
something happened where like there was
a tva and then like they got corrupted
by the time twisters maybe who knows
um but yeah i know that's a cool theory
um
let's look at another option though um
maybe it was some other past variant
loki who created the tva in the
timekeepers like there could be some
alpha
loki who views all other loki's as a
threat and targets loki specifically and
that's why oh if you're a loki
you're going in the break you know that
tends to be a lot of theories that i
think are appearing online that you know
x equals loki that rents layer equals
loki that mobius equals look you know
um it's very very possible um
so far i i think it might go in another
direction based off of what we've seen
rather than just like everyone equals
loki just because they did that in
episode two that
this other or episode one really that
the variant they're seeking is loki
uh if like everyone equals loki it it
starts to just feel like that amazing
short story the egg uh that i love where
everything is everything
by the end of it i don't know
i think viewers some viewers might be
like huh you know um
i don't know we would be excited though
it'd be really cool if everybody in the
tva was loki but yeah
i don't think that they're going that
route because i feel like it would make
the loki less special i don't know
right a little bit yeah um and we
already did that once with sylvia saying
that's not about you and i think it
worked
fine then um but to keep doing it it
would reduce her
impact you know reduce everyone's impact
you know delude it a bit as we would say
um now the option c is that perhaps like
no one really created the the tva or the
time keepers like it could just be like
a self-perpetuating clock that's
decentralized that's just always kind of
been there
and it's just moving forward under the
orders of some automated timekeepers or
miss minutes they're just
representative of the automation that
runs this place
maybe just some divine cosmic force at
the beginning of time created this but
it's not that important there's not a
man behind the curtains in this version
that i think would be really interesting
have you ever heard of something called
you're a time travel man so
you definitely probably have the
bootstrap paradox
no explain that okay so excited to have
something i don't know
this is like this is from a doctor who
episodes so like i'm not super oh got it
oh so um but i think it's a real paradox
so
basically it's like a time traveler goes
back in time and he wants to meet
beethoven but beethoven doesn't exist
but he has all of beethoven's like
symphonies so he becomes beethoven
so like like did beethoven ever exist
or like because he was beethoven so like
the tva
could be like i don't know like this
weird time loop like who created the tva
who knows but like
someone i don't know went back and like
i don't know maybe it's like this weird
time loop type thing
i'm explaining the bootstrap paradox
terribly but like
no that um a lot of sense in t it is
kind of like a predestined like your
destiny is to go back in time and become
beethoven
it's almost like the very act of
introducing
the possibility of time travel in a
universe um
through destiny creates these weird
bureaucracies where someone in the
future will have gone back to do this
you know
like it's just dropping in or opening
that can of worms
uh just that simple act the moment that
happens all these weird things spring up
just because time travel is possible and
theoretically
anything could have been altered um
that's kind of the
uh kind of the logic by which the fourth
option that
i think you guys all know where we're
going here uh exists in the marvel
comics
because i think at the end of the day mt
someone was puppeting the timekeepers in
that moment because notice when sylvie
cut off the head of the middle one the
other two laughed
robot laughter one of our friends is
dead
so that brings us to option d uh and
i think some other self-interested
powerful being with fascist goals but
doesn't want his face to be shown could
have created this hypocritical legal
bureaucracy to enforce
his exact vision of how he needs time to
flow so it doesn't present him any
obstacles
and who is more of an obstacle than loki
so you want to prune as many loki's as
you can because
that you know demigod is going to get in
the middle of your plans
if we're looking at the comics that top
suspect is
kangaroo
the guy we've been talking about since
you know uh
as soon as we knew the show was
happening we're like hey
where are you king i know you're coming
okay we know he's coming
now um kang of course is the ultimate
time travel villain of the marvel comics
he's
the upcoming villain of ant-man the wasp
quantomania gonna be played by jonathan
majors now majors i believe has denied
appearing in loki and maybe he's telling
the truth maybe he's lying
who knows but depending on how the mcu
frames kang's power set
kang would potentially have the power to
set up an institution that can transcend
time and a very limited range of options
that he wants
uh he is kind of like a time god you
know um
i have in recent weeks held back on kang
just because you know i don't want to
repeat of mephisto
but i think right now making ravana rent
slayer such a prominent character in the
series is a huge tell because they could
have chosen
any other tva judge from the comics the
tva has a ton of judges
they could have made up a judge but they
named her ravona renslayer they
they pick that character for a reason
and i think that reason is because
she is kang's love interest she has this
connection to kang and in this episode
we
we started to see a lot more about rinse
layer we learned that she used to be a
hunter
uh we really see how she is personally
invested in keeping the timekeepers
secret
she friendzoned moby is so hard uh and
she was able to ascend to judge status
despite losing her variant in the middle
of a trial
i mean she's got to be in she's got to
be benefiting from some kind of special
treatment from whomever is running the
tva right
it's just it's really weird and like in
the preview for this episode they did um
emphasize that pen
that they talked about in episode one
was it um the
high school pen and so i'm just
wondering if like
that there's a connection there between
like i don't know kang
and this high school where like maybe
ravona is
living like a secret side life or maybe
she's living a side life with kang
like i don't know but like because like
they're in charge of the timeline
they're in charge of all these people's
lives
so they might want to live an actual
life themselves because why would they
have to be
you know these bureaucratic people when
they're in charge so like i'm gonna go
and live a real life and like me and
kang are gonna have a kid in high school
and whatever
so that's my weird like i don't know
half theory going on there but yes
i think he pointed out uh an important
clue there mt because
the way rance layer collects these
different relics from these different
prune timelines felt kind of creepy this
episode for sure
and it is similar to the way kang builds
up chronopolis
he it is kind of like his retirement
pleasure kingdom
that is made up it's like kind of a
collage of different relics of different
architecture from uh different timelines
that he has conquered
uh and it's like his glorified trophy
room and you see
rensselaer doing it on this smaller
scale like you can imagine the two of
them he
is like using her to maintain order
within the tva so that no one rebels
maybe
uh whereas like promising her this kind
of like
is you know promising her the world the
moon essentially just like
let's just get the timeline exactly as i
need it we'll use this bureaucracy
everyone will just trust it inherently
because it feels like a legal
you know authority uh and then as soon
as it's done
we're done baby we're done you and i hey
maybe she feels like kind of like uh you
know stockholm syndrome too maybe she's
like terrified of him
maybe okay i'll keep your seat stockholm
syndrome is real like it's so it's the
weirdest thing but it's for real
yeah um i just you know i'm trying to
look at this logically at this point
and like you know when we were watching
one division mephisto there were a lot
of signs pointing to mephisto i think
that's what a lot of people miss when
they make fun of me for like going so
hard on mephisto is like if you're
actually watching this show
it wasn't just like a couple mentions of
the word devil it was just like
the the fact that they brought in agatha
harkness specifically as a witch
and then we end in her witch dungeon and
she has the dark hold
these are all kind of like kind of a
check uh list of
specific things that you're looking for
if you're gonna do a mephisto story
um but uh by the end you know we had
fewer and fewer episodes it's like well
if agatha is the big bad
you know then they're probably not going
to have another big bad beyond her
now we're at episode 4 and loki two
episodes left
the people we thought were the big bad
are not actual threats so it leaves this
void of like well then who is so we're
kind of at this point now of
well it's okay to kind of look out and
see who
would be the the villain of the series
uh
loki a version of loki could be that but
like the
post-credits scene are like all these
alternate loki's so how satisfying would
it be to have like
another evil loki we already met like a
very
loki variant every episode we need a new
loki variant this is true but at the
same time though
all of these loki vari i mean as far as
we can tell they seem to be
on the side of good which is very unlike
for the you know for the for the loki
character in in the marvel universe
so i feel like there could be a chance
though of there being just
one just truly evil loki it's like all
right yeah don't forget
loki's still an evil character to some
degree so like there has to be
like that contrast loki of like all
right we have to hibelson loki he used
to be bad but now he's good but there
still has to be some type of evil loki
because loki the character still has to
exist in that mischievous
you know evil form i don't know right i
and i think that's that's
totally possible i i won't i won't
negate that possibility at all and i
i think one thing that this show is
showing us is that
uh loki's don't have to follow that
archetypal role
they can be whatever they want true and
i think it's trying to
we've already seen evil loki in the
first avengers film
in thor so it has been more interesting
to see a broader range of morality on
the show so just to have
go back to one who's just evil loki like
i don't
know for me if it would have the same
impact maybe they will and maybe i'll
love it you know episode six
um but i think you need to bring in
someone else who either
you know maybe a loki variant who's gone
too far and then transformed his
identity into someone like kang
um i don't want to pin all our hopes
showing up in the show i've learned that
you know uh
you might have that blow up in your face
but like realistically
you know i was thinking it might be he
who remains but richard e grant is
playing a different character at this
point
we don't have big bads currently it just
leaves a huge opening for kang
or someone like him to appear so i'm
thinking
it's gonna be kang or it's gonna be some
original character uh it's gonna be
zarco the tomorrow man the most evil
villain of all time
sorry the second song it's not zarco uh
but yeah it's like it does leave it
completely open for any
time-based villain to pop in and be the
villain of the show so like
and kang is the most logical in the mcu
right now so like
it makes sense to bring up kang and
honestly it would be weird if we didn't
consider king first
because right now likely in many ways
it's the most likely yes um so do we
want to give odds to that
like it's a kang yeah how good do you
feel
that kang will appear in this show in
this show because i'm terrified right
now of doing this
i know but like it's fine we marvel
scientists bro it's okay if we're wrong
but no i think that because quantum
mania is so soon and
because kang is a big focus and because
of the name quantum mania it's a very
time focused name
i would say the odds are probably 60 40.
i don't know i don't know if that's yeah
before this episode mt i probably would
have put it at maybe 25
uh just because like oh i mean the show
the time keepers may just be the villain
but now the time keepers are killed and
richie grant is playing different a
different character
i think uh i think it's more likely it's
more likely than not
i'll say that sixty percent so
we do have to consider richard e grant
loki because he
is playing classic loki and that is that
classic
mischievous you know not good loki
so like maybe he could just be like hey
let's like let's all gang together
loki's and do our thing and then like
psych now i'm i backstabbed you all and
now i'm the real bad guy haha i gotcha
because it's richard grant it's richard
e grant he's a big name he's richie
grant he's a big name
i would just say it would be weird to
reveal him in like a three shot as
opposed to just him
you know we're just him i'd say oh he's
still the villain but the fact that we
got kid loki we got loka gator
we got boastful loki it's it seems like
all those like junkyard dudes in the
trailer footage are all going to be
different
you know loki's in different ways so
like he just seems like the
the elder of that loki cult who's like
this is where we live
now we're all kings here i hope they
assemble all the loki's and they all
like march together like
we're not gonna take it just watch the
tv
[Laughter]
all right we have so much we gotta talk
about this episode um
so before we get to that here's some big
news the manscaped engineering team has
created the lawnmower
4.0 trimmer and it is available in the
usa
and canada thanks to manscape for
sponsoring this episode by the way join
the over 2 million men worldwide who
trust
manscape with this exclusive offer 25
off and free worldwide shipping with the
code marvel manscape.com the
craftsmanship and details of the 4.0 are
next level empty
their advanced ceramic blade and skin
safe technology
so good it's probably what the tva has
next to their bathroom sinks
so it won't erase you from the timeline
if you make a mistake that's what the
skin safe technology is for that was in
the 3.0 not the 4.0
yeah now the lawnmower 4.0 has a travel
lock a 4 000
led spotlight and allows you to
customize your trim with
four guard lengths the optimized
lawnmower 4.0 trimmer is waterproof so
you can groom in the shower and it's got
wireless charging
get 20 off plus free shipping with the
code marvel at manscape.com your balls
will thank you
you're 20 off and free shipping with the
code marvel at manscape.com that's 20
off with free shipping at mainscape.com
use the code marvel unlock your
confidence
use the right tools for the job with
manscape we also want to thank magic
spoon for sponsoring this video a lot of
us are trying to eat better healthy
breakfast doesn't have to be boring
though magic spoon is the amazing
flavors you love but without the bad
stuff magic spoon is zero grams of sugar
13 to 14 grams of protein only four net
grams of carbs in each serving
there's only 140 calories a serving it's
keto friendly gluten free grain free soy
free low carb and gmo free
order yourself a variety pack that comes
with four flavors cocoa fruity frosted
and peanut butter and they get wild and
mix up some cocoa and peanut butter
flavors in the same bowl it tastes like
a peanut butter cup
so go to magicspoon.com marvel to grab a
variety pack and try today and be sure
to use our promo code marvel at checkout
to save five dollars off your order
and magic spoon is so confident in their
product it's backed with a 100 happiness
guarantee so if you don't like it for
any reason they'll refund your money no
questions asked remember get your next
delicious bowl of guilt free
marvel and cereal at good marvel to save
five dollars off thank you to magic
spoon for sponsoring this episode and
our friends at blue chew sponsored this
episode thank you blue chew we have
a boner sorry blue chew has a unique
online service that delivers
the same active ingredients as viagra
and cialis but in chewable form at a
fraction of the cost blue chew is an
online prescription service so no
doctor's office or pharmacy trips that
ships right to your door in a discreet
package
you sign up at bluetooth.com consult
with one of their licensed medical
providers and once you're approved you
receive your prescription within days
their license medical providers work
with you to find the right ingredient in
strength and blue chew is chewable just
like it says in the name which is great
for folks that don't like swallowing
pills
so if you could benefit from some extra
confidence when it's time to perform
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information
and we got a special deal for our
audience try bluetooth free when you use
the promo code inside marvel at checkout
just pay five dollars in shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code inside marvel
to receive your first month free and we
thank bluetooth for sponsoring the show
all right empty let's get back to this
episode of loki let's get it so wait a
damn minute
where is loki in this post-credits scene
and who are these other loki's
that is a good question because in the
credits they're listed as kid loki
boswoloki classic loki and gator loki so
yeah i don't think he's credited as
skater loki that's just what we say
i that'd be great if he was credited as
like gator lucky yeah
and he's played by uh uh al the
alligator he's just he has acting
credits he has an imdb page everything
it's like the most famous gator in the
world
um so but they are they do seem to be
around the ruins of
new york as we've seen in the trailer so
we see the avengers tower behind them
and this this does seem to be uh a
timeline where
maybe possibly the new quinoaf at the
end of avengers 1.
oh okay which is uh very interesting to
me and i think that this could actually
potentially be a timeline where maybe
phil coulson lived this is something
that i've been thinking about over the
past couple of days
because phil coulson's death is
extremely important to
the end of avengers 1 because if phil
costa doesn't die the avengers don't
assemble in time and then the nuke goes
off
and new york explodes so maybe this
timeline is where they're sending all of
these loki's this
this like really shitty timeline it's
like all right it's the worst
who cares let's throw all of our trash
there so who knows
uh that's just what i think where do you
think they're at um i i think that's a
really cool theory mt
i thought about that too that this could
be like a an alternate version of the
battle of new york
i'm just wondering if that uh avengers
tower if it is avengers tower or stark
tower at the end of that movie like this
could be some time later
i in that shot at we don't see how much
of the a
is blown off um and i wonder like i
don't know what
how powerful of a nuke the us government
fired at new york in that scene
but i would imagine it would flatten
more of the city wouldn't leave any of
the structures standing that way this
looks more like twisted and weird more
like a choice
to design it this way like i wonder if
like
whoever is running the tva if it is kang
if it is someone else
had this very specific uh future in new
york that has been wrecked
uh and it banishes all the loki's that
it prunes to this place
to uh just kind of keep him them here in
exile
uh and have them like fight over each
other like maybe new york was like
fine at first but then after like three
or four loki's get sent there they all
just keep fighting over it
it's like world's more loki right right
right and they're using different spells
and that's why you have this weird plane
in the middle of city
i mean not just central park it looks
like
certain areas have been flattened uh and
a shockwave has just disheveled certain
buildings a certain way
but like i wonder if like there's a
president loki because like everyone
here is a loki
it's like the citadel essentially but if
the citadel of ricks was
like a prison that they're all kept in
that is so
interesting i wonder if everybody that's
pruned goes into a timeline where it's
all them it's like a hell of them every
person
that'd be crazy oh how horrible
um yeah cause i wonder if like when
other people get pruned i feel like
they're sent back to whatever their home
timeline is that they were taken from
with their memories restored
uh but when loki gets pruned i think
loki is a specific
thorn in the paw of kang or someone like
that right
like they're like they have to go
recognize all loki's as a threat so i
have to keep all the loki's on
this elba you know um so that they can't
come back and kill me
because they're gonna that's it's so
interesting why they wouldn't just
outright just kill all the loki's
like why even just do this weird
timeline thing like why just like all
right i'm just going to shoot you with
the head
you're dead you're not coming back i
thought that too empty maybe it's just
like for one killing a loki's really
hard because he's a badass he's a
demigod it's not easy just to
he'll just like reveal himself to be a
duplication cast
you know um but secondly maybe that was
the play at the beginning maybe loki's
were killed
uh but then whoever you know we're
calling him kang but whoever's running
the tva
recognized that like oh there's it's
like whack-a-mole
there's so many loki's there's infinite
loki's
and the only way to permanently
guarantee is to just like
keep pruning them off and keeping them
alive in this place
but if you kill them off they could get
resurrected in some other form
you know uh his soul could go uh
incarnate somewhere else and then you
have no idea where he is so the point is
is you capture him
and you put him in your fish tank that
is an excellent i'm glad you brought
that up because
now i'm thinking about like what if
there is a higher authority like you
know not not like a kang or anything but
like you know like uh like i said before
like uh
the living tribunal or maybe more chaos
and master order
um that are higher in charger than the
tva so like when
like you said a loki does get killed
like physically killed with like a
bullet or something
they get reincarnated because like the
chaos element that
silly brings up in this episode has to
exist like it has to exist to
make the multiverse function so like
like you said this is a great reason why
we put the loki's into another timeline
it's like you're alive
like you we we're not gonna kill you but
like we have to let
we have to control the chaos because we
want to be in charge so that's an
excellent that's right i like that you
brought that up um
shifting gears a bit empty wait a day a
minute mobius said tva brought in cree
titans and vampires yes is this a blade
setup
it's gotta be bro it's got to be bro i
hope so
like they they got to be setting up
blade they got to be sort of setting up
the ultimate universe mobius like you
know it's or morbius i keep saying like
mix it up we got a morbius and a mobius
morbius and mobius mobius is teasing
morbius ah enough
i mean technically this is not the first
mention of vampires in the mcu we in
thor ragnarok court said that
three-pronged wooden
uh weapon could kill three vampires
standing close together which
at the time was such a great what we do
in the shadows reference from taika but
um yeah vampires do exist somewhere in
this universe now we're getting a second
one from the tva
um yeah i mean i think with the dark
holes emergence in one division
we're gonna start seeing more and more
of this stuff supernatural stuff get
layered into the mcu uh because with
witches and the darkhold you also have
things like
uh zombies vampires werewolves etc it's
true and like it's been rumored
that uh we're gonna get dr voodoo in
doctor strange too hopefully fingers
crossed i don't know if that's still the
plan
but like and dr voodoo of course deals
with you know the undead and and dead
creatures so like we're gonna get all
that [ __ ] the undead vampires all that
stuff
it's gonna be great hopefully dr strange
too is the is where
we get vampires introduced because i
feel like that's the most logical i mean
i'm ready for some blade announcements
because
that marshall announcement at comic con
2019 was like the big
uh announcement at the end of it yes he
just wears a blade hat
and we have heard nothing about it since
then that's all we needed was the blade
hat to tie this over
i mean i'm still clinging to that i love
it all right
a bit more to talk about uh but first uh
one more person we want to thank for
sponsoring this episode bespoke post so
bespoke posts
a new lineup of essential box of awesome
collections for guys are guaranteed to
upgrade your life
no matter what you're into some of my
favorite boxes from the past have
great shirts that i wear all the time
cool kitchen equipment some fun travel
gear
whether you're out taming the wilderness
or taking your home bar to
pro level heights bespoke bus only sends
guys the best stuff every month
box of awesome has collections for every
part of your life the new explorer box
comes with cool gear that you can use to
go
off in the wilderness and shoe lip box
comes with everything you need to make
some fancy mint julep cocktails
so to get started take the quiz at box
of awesome.com your answers will help
them
pick the right box of awesome for you
they release new boxes every month
across
a ton of different categories it's free
to sign up and you can skip a month or
cancel anytime
each box only costs 45 bucks but has
over 70 dollars worth of gear inside
get 20 off your first monthly box when
you sign up at box of awesome.com and
enter the code marvel at checkout
that's box of awesome.com code marvel
for 20 off your first box
so we were talking about this a bit
earlier mt but wait a damn minute
where did mobius get pruned to we know
where loki's get pruned
where did these other where did c20
where does mobius where would renslayer
get pruned to
that is a really interesting question
well me being of the church of
mobius is loki as since episode one i
think that mobius could
actually be in this timeline where oh
and we just haven't seen him yet um he's
just chilling there he's like why am i
here what is this
how did i get here wow i mean we're not
getting the wrong he says
everything but wow
wow every cow i feel like that was in
his contract he's like listen i'm not
doing the wow thing all right if you
want me in this show
no wow we're hurt down
every other day that would be so
hilarious if you went into like
the that moment with sif and loki's like
how we're at thou loki or something like
that just like that'd be hilarious
so i like that idea i i think you know
he even said
uh what's gonna happen like oh where was
i where did you get me from i
i bet i was riding around on my jet ski
i love how much he said the word jet ski
and then he's like
driving i wish i had a jet ski i'm gonna
get a big jet ski
real fast fast jet ski right he's like
if these are gonna be my last words
they're gonna say jet ski as much as
possible
i hope that he uh i hope he's on a jet
ski somewhere that's what i hope that's
why
that would make rent slayer's pruning of
him a lit little less cold-hearted
um because we saw uh sylvie pruned some
tva agents uh
last episode you know and i hope that
every time you do that it's like the
matrix you're freeing this person you're
unplugging them
yeah and i hope he just wakes up and
then he's kind of grateful that he was
pruned because he's
either mid jet ski or maybe he's a a jet
ski salesman who can't afford a jet ski
himself
right he's just like he just wakes up on
the stretch like in the middle of a jet
ski scores like oh my god i fell asleep
i was like you know that's a good thing
about a jet ski most of the time you can
fall asleep on a jet ski or just kind of
tune out doze out on a jet ski and
you're fine even if you fall off you
have those keys
that like are attached to your wrist so
if you fall off the jet ski and
immediately powers down the engine
you're fine it's the ultimate machine i
know
i i'm saying like i'm not saying get
super drunk or high and go on a jet ski
that's illegal and yeah dangerous please
be safe but you
could and it's not as dangerous as doing
that behind the wheel of a car it's true
that's what makes jet ski so great as
you're just
roaming around a big open body of water
and everyone can see and hear you
they'll get out of your way do you know
how many people die from
jet ski collisions it's very little i'm
assuming i have no idea what the numbers
are on them
some jet ski sales people countries are
like actually
you know number one killer of people jet
skis yeah
we call them uh uh aquatic organ donors
[Laughter]
you want a waterlogged kidney go to a
jet ski owner
the jet skis are the vending machines of
the sea basically because apparently
vending machines are super deadly
i don't know how but here they are
editor john
reports that based on uscg report
600 to 700 jet ski accidents are
reported each year
resulting in around 40 deaths so this
tendency has been declining over the
past decade
i wonder if that's um deaths per jet ski
or just because fewer people have jet
skis unfortunately
um but 40 deaths not that bad of jet ski
accidents
yeah i mean obviously like it's it's not
that bad of a number
it could be high right yeah way higher
one uh last question i want to ask you
before before i jump over to the
breakdown mt
wait a day a minute will loki and sylvie
create the multiverse of madness with
love
is that what the show is i think they're
pulling an interstellar
they're pulling the interstellar
love is the ultimate power in the cosmos
honestly
maybe because that that's what this
episode seemed to have done because like
as soon as they
had their little moment on lament that
temporal energy monitor went like
straight to redline like right away
because usually it
slowly goes to red line but like it's
just like nope the power of love we're
going straight up
um so yeah i i think that that could be
a huge key to how all of this happens
somehow
i don't know how but like i think love
or at least the love of their these two
variants specifically
because uh it's just very unlikely it's
just like yeah i think that could be a
key to how all this goes down but what
do you think no i think you're right and
i think it's the um
specifically when loki's uh when a loki
falls in love with a loki
he loves loki um sorry
no please that was beautiful i loved it
uh we just lost
a million subscribers um
yeah i think uh the fear of
the time variants authority is loki's
specifically
and i think when loki's combine their
strengths as opposed to warring against
each other
that's the worst case scenario because i
think the idea is that loki's
might have the potential to be a
nexus being and if they can ever
reach that true potential that's the
fear so you keep them squabbling with
each other
in this like uh ruins of new york
playground
you know this sandbox um but if any two
lookies are ever free
and are able to kind of uh find that
inner awakening with each other
uh that's the worst pruning so i don't
think it creates like a
um a multiverse necessarily
but it does present a threat a great
threat to whoever is running the tva
and i think that's what these branches
represent now because i think
everything they've told us about the tva
is [ __ ]
so we don't know if it's going to lead
directly to a multiverse but it is going
to lead to a version of
reality that um kang or whoever's
running this
organization hates and fears i would
imagine
knowing from what we know of kang in the
comics he likes a multiverse
right i don't think he wants to see he
has his own timeline that he's building
but ultimately he likes other branch
timelines out there because those are
other resources that he can use to
uh feed himself at the end of all time
right so maybe there are other branch
timelines there are other branch
timelines and variants out there that
the show has
kind of ignored um but it's just kind of
presenting this mono timeline view of
reality
that and and putting up blinders to
everything else no i like what you just
said because like
when you talk you say magical things
there like i hope you know that you
sometimes wonder
no i like what you said because like
that got me thinking if
kang is this being that loves the
multiverse and wants the multiverse to
thrive
and we have ravona rensslayer who's like
you know
working on behalf of these fake
timekeepers what if
kang conquered in the past the time
keepers or the time keepers
like took him like took it from him took
him hostage it's like hey rent slayer
we got your boy you got to do what we
say and like you know keep this lie up
and you know we got we got kang over
here so like maybe she's like has a gun
to her head by these whoever's running
the timekeepers
and she has to do this these shitty
things to keep kang alive
i don't know yeah i mean i think you're
right that she does have a gun to her
head she said just do it just prune me
like she wanted it to end in that moment
i think she wanted to be free to
wherever she came from
to just not have to do this anymore um i
wonder if like
it could have been the other way around
maybe kang conquered the tva
and then replaced these things with
puppets and then he's really pulling the
strings of it now
dang i hope i really hope that they're
not in an abusive relationship please be
okay
i hope that kang's not like being like
ravona like do all this evil [ __ ]
because i don't know anyway
you could cut that i don't know no i
mean that is kind of what i mean thanos
has abusive relationships with all of
his children right
so it's true it's it's we've seen it
before in the mcu
um well there you have it uh so that is
it for this episode of inside marvel so
again the breakdown of the episode
four is going to be on the channel
tomorrow keep an eye out for that
uh don't forget to check out our many
great loki merch options at new
yorkstarsmerch.com
follow mt at mastertainment follow me at
eavos follow new rockstars subscribe to
inside marvel wherever you get your
podcasts
and uh thank you for watching and we'll
close with our favorite moment of the
episode
[Music]
so